Російська православна церква давно співає в унісон з Кремлем.
Днями патріарх Кирило буквально благословив російські війська на війну проти України.
Під час літургії передав очільнику Росгвардії Серпневу ікону Божої Матері.
Це образ Богородиці, яка нібито явилася російському війську під час Першої світової війни.
Нехай вона надихає молодих воїнів, які складають присягу, які вступають на шлях захисту вітчизни.
Вручаю його вам, Вікторе Васильовичу.
Хочу сказати, що так, не все йде так швидко, як хотілося б...
Але ми йдемо до наміченої цілі крок за кроком.
Перемога буде за нами, а ця ікона захищатиме російське воїнство і прискорюватиме нашу перемогу.
Росія використовує віру разом зі зброєю.
Що протиставляють цьому українські церкви?
І як релігія реагує на війну?
Навіть під сигнал повітряної тривоги в Києві триває служба.
Так військові капелани благословляють українських воїнів, які боронитимуть Київ.
Це молитва і благословення українського воїна та зброї їхньої на захист землі української,
життя за своєю спиною і правди Божої загалом.
Церква має практику благословляти все, чим користується людина.
Тим більше зброю, використовуючи котру воїн боронить правду Божу на нашій землі.
У Православній церкві України заявили, що вбивати ворога, який прийшов у чужий дім - не гріх.
Всеукраїнська Рада церков, куди входять усі найбільші релігійні спільноти,
одноголосно закликає Росію припинити війну, а світ - закрити небо над Україною.
Загарбники вже зруйнували щонайменше три десятки церков, мечетей і синагог.
Найбільше - православних храмів. Серед них і церкви Московського патріархату.
Це храм УПЦ Московського патріархату у Львові.
Тут нам не дали офіційних коментарів про ставлення до війни.
Але наголосили, що Львівська єпархія свою позицію вже висловила.
Вона зафіксована навіть на листівках поруч із храмом: церква засуджує російську агресію.
Загалом у Московському патріархаті не все так однозначно.
Предстоятель УПЦ МП митрополит Онуфрій закликав Росію припинити братовбивчу війну,
хоча продовжує поминати патріарха Кирила у богослужіннях.
Сталася трагедія. Росія розпочала воєнні дії проти України.
Українська православна церква завжди була, є і буде зі своїм народом.
Ми сьогодні просимо вас, Владімір Владімірович, зупинити війну.
Наші народи - український народ і російський народ - народи, які вийшли з однієї Київськой дніпровської купелі.
Поминати патріарха Кирила відмовилися вже 15 з 53 єпархій УПЦ МП.
За словами релігієзнавців, це потужне висловлення непокори
й ознака відсутності єдності у церквах Московського патріархату.
Я звертаюся до патріарха московського Кирила.
Я припиняю поминати ваше ім'я за богослужінням у нашому храмі.
Це моя відповідь на ваше мовчання під час війни Росії з Україною
і потурання в усьому президенту Росії Путіну, що призвело до цієї війни.
Ми вважали вас батьком, а ви виявилися гіршим за вітчима. Бог вам суддя.
Тим часом на Львівщині, Рівненщині, Івано-Франківщині храми УПЦ МП перевірила поліція.
Адже місцеві жителі підозрювали, що там можуть переховувати зброю чи диверсантів.
За даними силовиків, нічого підозрілого не виявили.
Православна церква України закликає парафії Московського патріархату приєднуватися до ПЦУ.
Адже майбутнього для УПЦ МП в Україні тут не бачать.
Мій прогноз це те, що Україна як демократична країна, очевидно, не буде робити так, як це часто роблять в Росії,
коли просто якусь релігійну організацію забороняють.
Але рівень підтримки суспільної, рівень підтримки парафіянами саме Московського патріархату
призведе до того, що ця структура в рази зменшиться після війни, після української перемоги.
І перетвориться в суспільно незначущу.
От в Україні існують, наприклад, старообрядці.
Вони існують історично вже декілька століть.
Але в суспільному полі про них не згадують, і знають про них хіба що спеціалісти.
Отець Тихон - греко-католицький священник.
У нього - своя історія, пов'язана з Росією.
Він - переселенець з Донбасу. З рідної Мар'їнки виїжджав під дулом кулеметів за активну проукраїнську позицію.
Я був у полоні - 12 діб - російської православної армії.
Мене звільнили, і після того вимога терористів була така, щоб я якнайдалі був від Донецька,
бо там лишалися мої парафіяни.
Логічно, що якнайдалі може бути від Донецька? Львів. Тож я вісім років уже у Львові.
Нині священник взявся за духовну зброю.
Щодня проводить обряд екзорцизму в наміренні Володимира Путіна.
Отець Тихон пояснює: нічого містичного в ритуалі немає.
Це проста молитва, яку духівник транслює онлайн - у закритій групі на Фейсбуці.
Ми будемо продовжувати нашу боротьбу і вона буде тривати стільки, скільки це буде потрібно.
Щоб досягнути того результату, який нам потрібен, тобто миру, спокою і перемоги в Україні.
До незвичної служби приєдналися ще кілька священників і три сотні вірян.
Отець Тихон вірить, що таке звернення до Бога допоможе змінити наміри російського президента й зупинити війну.
Або відбудеться навернення його, тобто переміна способу думок, грецькою мовою "метанойя" -
людина починає думати по-інакшому, раціонально, морально, духовно,
і відповідно перестає чинити те зло, яке вона зараз чинить.
Або, буває так, що і такого не відбувається, то тоді, за словами апостола Павла,
у нього є в його листі першому до Коринтян такий вислів "віддати тіло у влада Сатани",
щоби Бог дозволив Сатані нашкодити тілу людини, щоб унаслідок цього відбулася переміна.
Через хворобу, через тілесне страждання, щоб людина змінилася.
Умовно кажучи, ритуал екзорцизму - це такий "Джавелін" проти Володимира Путіна.
У мене є цей "Джавелін". І буде гріх мені, якщо він буде десь лежати і я не буду його використовувати.
Крім таких ритуалів отець Тихон займається більш звичною психотерапією.
Має відповідну освіту й двадцятирічну практику.
Нині допомагає багатьом, зокрема й переселенцям, пережити складні часи.
Синдром жертви вмикається у багатьох.
Моє завдання, щоб він не опанував людину.
Усвідомити його і зробити все можливе, щоб не стати цією жертвою, психологічно, на ментальному рівні жертвою.
Не бути жертвами - моє основне гасло. Українці не мають бути жертвами. Ми маємо бути переможцями.
Саме за духовною підтримкою люди йдуть до храму.
Олена з донькою Аліною приїхали до Львова з передмістя Києва, де йдуть бої.
Насамперед пішли до церкви.
По-перше, це місце, де можна якось зцілитися духовно.
Я навіть відчуваю, що коли сюди приходиш, то всі молитви людей, які зібрані в цьому місці,
тебе надихають, щоб ти міг далі витримати те, що на нас чекає.
Це храм Успіння Богородиці, що належить Львівській єпархії ПЦУ.
Отець-диякон Юрій проводить за лаштунки.
Оце наше сховище, ми тут ховаємося, як б'ють.
А ще диякон Юрій показує колишні трапезну й редакцію церковної газети.
Нині ці приміщення радше нагадують гуманітарний штаб.
Аптечки ось. Це українці з Німеччини нам передали.
Українці з Польщі нам передали, ми вже посортували, що є.
Це, наприклад, бинти, перев'язочні матеріали, це рукавички, те, що нині бракує в Україні - вата, марля.
Вчора ми відправили дві машини на схід України, це на північ і на південь роз'їхалися наші друзі, до речі, священики-капелани.
А ось це частково ліки залишилися, бо ми частину роздаємо між людьми,
які перебувають вимушено тут у нас, в Галичині.
За словами диякона, кожен зі служителів храму прийняв у себе вдома вірян з різних регіонів, які тікали від війни.
Церковна громада збирається на вихідних, аби готувати для військових домашню їжу.
Спільнота парафіян об'єднана, як ніколи.
Зараз громада настільки сильно тримається,  хоча ми розпорошені,
наші помешкання знаходяться в радіусі цілого Львова, або й за межами Львова,
багато людей приїжджають із сіл, які є біля Львова, але ми настільки кріпкі,
що лишень почалася війна, наші люди тут зібрали лише ліків приблизно на 80 тисяч.
Ірина приїхала до Львова з Ірпеня.
Її син залишився в Києві, допомагає обороні.
Релігійна спільнота стала для жінки родиною, а церква - другим домом.
Любов дає, смирення дає, спокій дає.
Тому що це дім наш, ну як сказати, ось ми знаходимося дома, і тут ми захищені.
Нині в багатьох містах і селах церковні дзвони замінили сигнали тривоги.
Але ці дзвони інші.
Ці дзвони лунають щодня о шостій вечора за Києвом.
Вони означають єднання і мають давати віру в краще і віру в перемогу.
Такий щоденний передзвін - ініціатива львів'ян.
Утім, мелодія солідарності з Україною так само лунає у Німеччині, Франції, Швейцарії, Іспанії.
Папа Римський молиться за український народ.
Франциск на наступний день після початку війни навіть відвідав посольство Росії,
хоча такий жест для понтифіка незвичний.
А ще Ватикан запропонував стати посередником для перемовин України з Росією.
Щоб не лише молитися, а й діяти заради миру.